uh so where do you guys go from here you
and Atlanta because obviously you guys
this I mean does this keep happening um
is is is is the the the the door off the
hinges now when it comes to dudes like
um definitely we're going to do more
[__] with other guys but I don't you
know we're not going to do like another
reality show to find the next guy that's
just going to [__] or whatever you know
for sure if we have an idea something
they'll take it to the next level then
we're down to do it but at this point I
think we're kind of plotting our next
moves I think that as like an overall
umbrella idea for plug talk we could
kind of take like any successful content
style last night I was thinking about
game shows a lot and just thinking like
because I know that some of those guys
like uh the the siden and the amp guys
and everything kaat and all them that
they do basically game shows that are
kind of like ripoffs of existing game
shows that people watch on TV right you
could do like the sex version makes
sense to me but we got to figure out cuz
like I think me and her are both looking
at like how we exit a plug talk at a
certain point like how do we build it
into a business that doesn't seem
entirely dependent on me and her and I
think we've taken some important steps
with that because we do we we do these
uh live org's consistently on the
channel we'll have well you'll have it
some of it on YouTube some of it on yeah
but we do like a big panel like you know
15 or 10 people talking or whatever and
then everybody goes and [__] but if we
could produce content that would
consistently do well and promotee the
porn side of things and make it x-rated
but then also be able to have a version
of it that goes on Instagram and Tik Tok
and everything I think that's perfect uh
so I think we need to like basically
figure that out because we want to have
another kid at some point so there's
going to be a shakeup in terms of Lena
not doing content for six months or
whatever at some point I was going to
say like is there have I mean there's
got to be like the end game's got to be
are you guys I mean you guys are going
to do this
forever not forever but I will say that
there's a lot of porn dudes like dread
dread is 50 no yeah shout out to him a
lot of porn dudes are like 50 at a
certain point before they hang it up I'm
talking about just like the the being
married with a performer being on camera
it feels like any time some of my
favorite porn stars have ever gotten
married they usually retire yeah I don't
know we're having fun with it honestly
if it wasn't fun then we wouldn't be
doing it but and is it is it ever like I
don't like you guys have always kind of
had this type of relationship where you
guys bring women in right to the fold so
I mean for me personally I would do plug
talk for free if I just got to [__] all
these girls exactly well that's what I
was going say it's like how do you ever
like you can never go back to just like
hey it's just me and you uh I think we
could I think like cuz has it ever been
that just me and her yeah I mean before
plug talk for sure there would be like
months and months and months where we
didn't hook up with anybody else
especially during the pregnancy and
stuff I kind of feel like as I've gotten
older like the threesome thing when I
was still a civilian was such like a
coveted thing like it was just I can
remember every threesome I ever had it
was just the most exciting thing in the
world to [__] two girls at the same time
now having done it hundreds and hundreds
of times I definitely feel like I could
just be a regular guy married hang out
married yeah definitely come home get
dinner what I'm going to be just chasing
chicks around on the club and [__] well
into my 40s I'm not really seeing it so
I feel like I could definitely be just
straight monogamous but I also feel like
if we were monog and we weren't doing
porn we would probably start sort of
being like oh well maybe we should [__]
this girl together maybe we should go
out with her maybe we should you know
find like I think we would still
probably find ways to want to explore a
little did you end up [__] Joe Smith
white uh
no but I would love to she when didn't
she pull up she never did nothing what'
you do we did the interview and I was
kind of tossing it out there like hey me
and you doing porn what do you think and
uh she didn't seem like it was off the
table but she's still married so in the
same way in like 2017 a rapper could go
on your platform and it changes their
life are you guys kind of like the
coveted platform for any porn chick to
try to get on to try to kind of change
the trajectory of their business on only
fans I mean definitely we a platform
that could do that I don't know like if
somebody wants to make a bunch of noise
by just doing a sex scene in general I
think we're like a great place for
somebody to pull up like I know that we
for sure mve the needle big time on that
teacher Brianna or whatever that you're
talking about um but yeah I mean I don't
know the market is very flooded in terms
of content you guys have your pick every
week I'm sure like ah we got x amount of
people trying to do this well we we have
enough episodes right now to not do it
till March so we we have you're [__]
you're just racking them up yeah some
weeks we'll do five or six how is DJ
miles oh she's a champion oh my God bro
I've been a fan of hers for a long time
on
Twitter I can't wait for that one to
come out her interview is mindblowing
she's very small she's five or 47 so
what was it was it 42 years old 47 she's
42 can you believe it [__] them Asians
they don't age bro insane [__] what kind
is she a Filipina or what is she yeah
Phil shout out to Filipino women and men
they do not age at all my my manager's
58 and he looks like he's 40 I had a
hell of a time not busting with her
man that [__] was overflowing was that
like one of the better like recent
because I'm I'm assuming like yes yeah
CJ mon she's hot she's Fir and it's
something about her just being this like
miniature sized human but still being
like basically a mil that was she's just
so professional the way she was hopping
on there you never [__] a [__] no
I'm still looking for the right one
there's I've seen a
few at least I've seen Twitter where
you're like oh yeah but it hasn't really
happened yet cuz like the thing about
[__] do you remember the old OG porn
star pinky I do so pinky to me was like
she was like just teetering on [__]
status was she really that small she was
built like a [__] I didn't know that
you know like midgets are real Stumpy
and thick you know what I'm saying [__]
she was just like are we canc I don't
know I dm'd pinky too I didn't hear back
from her although my girl probably
definitely doesn't remember pinky so it
might have been kind of hard explaining
I think pinky is um I I don't I haven't
seen her recently so I I couldn't speak
I saw a picture yeah there was a whole
thing where she was like they took
pictures of her in the [__] Walmart
or some [__] and she wasn't looking so
hot she wasn't looking so great and
everybody's making a big deal out of it
and it's like bro you could take the
hottest porn girl in the game and you
show her with no makeup shitty photo
it's Happ with ice spice people try to
talk [__] about ice spice like ice spice
when you see that you realize how
confused a lot of guys are because the
way chicks look when they're on camera
fully doled up and the way they look 99%
of the time it's not the same thing and
this is that's like a little boy thing
of like realizing like oh [__] girls
look different with concealer and
mascara and all this [__] so it's I kind
of I [__] like have you never had a
girlfriend before does she look the same
from when you guys but there there is
such a thing where like some girls are
hot as [__] with makeup and still really
hot without makeup and then there's some
girls where the difference is quite
drastic it is drastic